We are hearing from folks in all sorts of
different areas. Let's go next to Richard
from Pueblo, Richard from Pueblo.
Hey, man, you guys hear me? Yes, I can. Cool,
it is big. I have one question and I'm not
sure the other two, but there could be comments
or questions, but as we say.
The day is going very well, yes.
I just heard today that the UN just started
to decriminalize cannabis. I wanted to know
your thoughts.
The UN voted to do it. What does that mean?
Where does the UN have jurisdiction?
They from what marijuana moment would say
is that they were making the claim that.
It is not a vote that will change the world
today, it's a vote that will be like a watershed
moment.
Did they vote to recommend countries decriminalized?
Is that what they did?
I used the term international control, dot,
dot, dot, whatever that means. OK.
So I was one of the you when they say international
control, does that mean like if you have a
ship, like a merchant going from UK to us
and I know it's in Canada, there's someone
from another country have the right to stop
that boat or is it like.
So here's what happened, I just looked it
up, the U.N. voted a U.N. commission, voted
to remove cannabis for medicinal purposes
from a category of the most dangerous drugs,
which could clear the way to expand research
and medical use there based in Vienna and
include 53 member states considered a series
of recommendations from the w h o. The most
important part is removing cannabis from schedule
four of the nineteen sixty one single convention
on narcotics. Experts say this will have no
impact at all on international controls because
governments still have jurisdiction. But many
countries look to global conventions for guidance.
OK, so this doesn't do anything. But it's
a signal from the UN that at this point they
believe cannabis for medical shouldn't be
classified as one of the most dangerous drugs.
So this is a very modest change, but not irrelevant.
And we should still support it.
All right. I mean, this is Texas, thank you,
sir. Also, you are called before on the show
basis on what is the DEA could be for. So
I have to ask you a dumb question. Don't laugh.
But the second question is, if I got the opportunity
to reform the DEA, would you be my practice
press secretary on the job?
I would not. No, that's not a job I'm interested
in.
Well, I hope you take it, but all right, Richard
from Pueblo, very, very good. An unusual phone
call and very strange audio tone there. But,
you know, always interested in various devices
that people sometimes used to call in.